hi and welcome from the Chess Club and
scholastic center of st. Louis my name
is Ryan and I'm Katherine and we both
lost seven year olds in the past year
and this is our new youtube series for
kids and beginners blunders of Katherine
and Ryan we make mistakes so you don't
have to so Katherine what is a blunder
Oh hitch in chess a blunder is a very
bad move
it is often caused by not paying
attention to what your opponent is doing
moving too fast we're simply not knowing
that your piece is under attack and just
fair warning the example I'm using today
isn't the last one yeah I bet it is
Katherine I bet it is
so did you know that in chess annotation
blunders are typically marked with
double question marks at the after the
move interesting fact Ryan since I'm in
fun effect here all right Ryan I think
first we should take a look at one of
your games all right Katherine in this
game I was playing black and white just
took my pawn in the B file and I am
about to blunder my move was b6 can you
pause the video and really look at their
board and see why that's a blunder so
the reason that's a blunder is that
white punishes black me for not castling
by taking the pawn if I capture the pawn
I lose the rook or if I move the bishop
I still lose the rook all right why do
you think you've wondered well Kevin I
blundered because my King was not safe I
didn't castle and I was not paying
attention to what my opponent was doing
Catherine let's take a look at one of
your games now I bet you blundered
pretty bad you would be correct
Brian what peace dear viewers of mine
because I am black is under attack at
the moment
if you said the night you are correct
put it okay in the heat of the moment I
did not notice that at all
so my pawn takes in the D file and boom
Knight gone down points and the lost
territory and really so this would be I
think an example of moving too quickly
and also neglecting knows a piece under
attack oh so you've seen the worst of
our moves now we want to see yours
please send your blunders to the email
account listed on the screen below and
we'll make it worth your while a call
out of the show and a mystery prize
right is that it for today that's it for
today thanks for watching well you
really hung that Knight now just drive